es tu es et tu et à toi et et coucou et
dit tu veux voir mon beau casse tête
bon alors ça c'est le casse-tête qu'on
devait faire cette semaine vous l'aviez
vu la semaine dernière ils étaient en
font cependant il a subi une petite
avarie qui va leur portée puisqu'il il
s'est complètement pété bon alors du
coup aujourd'hui on va faire le tonneau
qu'est ce que le togo c'est un casse
tête de niveau 2 niveaux convient
d'ailleurs ce que des fois je dis des
conneries tonneau casse tête on nous dit
quoi on nous dit que c'est un
difficultés extrêmes on nous dit que
c'est un casse-tête difficulté 4 sur 5
on nous dit que c'est un casse-tête en
3d grosso modo faut le déplier et après
faut leur pouilles et du coup parce que
celle inverse de dépouiller dans le
dépouiller j'en appelle à l'homme de la
situation mon gars sur mon gars m'ont
influenceurs alors tu vas tu es plus des
tonneaux et après j'essaye de leur poule
y est ok loïc oui
ah oui c'est vrai qu'au petit dépôt le
tonneau ce qui est déjà un casse-tête en
soi bien le bonjour
alors aujourd'hui pour la résolution de
castets le tonneau le tonneau fabriqué
en 1972 tu m'as 10 à 50 voilà elle bat
déjà sa commande
1 on voit que j'ai pris du ce qu'ils
voient là et hop
chiquita qu ils ont bloqué au même
endroit ce gala qu'est ce que dit non
pourquoi non c'est parce que je regarde
comment s'est fait parce que c'est bien
fait elle a été fabriquée par quelqu'un
qui sait faire les choses bien
big up à cette personne
quoi c'est le tonnelier tonnelier là on
est quoi te ne liez tonolli on dit qu
est ce que tu as fini de le décrier
ouais c'est maintenant que ça se
complique et pourquoi pas se compliquer
à un accord pas du tout hockey comme une
figure ils ont classe je suis sur un
casse-tête en fait même dire que je je
touche partout et il ne se passe rien
ouais ça semblait ça fait ça fait seul
mythe qu'on a lancé la vidéo loïc 5020
mais ça semble sais pas ap bien malin
maintenant parce que tu vas voir tout à
l'heure bien moins plus faire le
mannequin je comprends pas là c'est
beaucoup voilà à bruges était
complètement d'accord soit côté pour
rejeter conquois oui oui on essaie de la
bêtise
non en fait c'est pas que je galérais et
que je voulais mettre un peu de suspense
dans la vidéo fait donc ce n'est pas
trop intense c'est fait voilà comment
c'est merci loïc au revoir on en est
quand même à 7 minutes de des
résolutions pourquoi il ya un bout de
bois là parce que tu me faisais pas
vraiment ok donc après sept minutes de
tournage après avoir retrouvé la pièce
que tu as planquer et si jamais tu en as
planque et d'autres après avoir une
publicité tu te rends compte quand même
à la vitesse à laquelle ça va nous avons
donc l'armature du club du casse-tête sa
forme déjà un tonneau un peu d'eau un
peu speed de là on peut dire déjà on a
un tonneau applaudissements ce programme
et on a les pièces alors j'ai été un
petit peu comme j'avais fait que la
pyramide qui avait fait tant débat je
vais ranger les pièces qui se
ressemblent ensemble parce que ça ça
m'avait aidé comme avaient été accomplis
ça c'est identique
ça c'est identique avec lumen ça donc
qu'est-ce que je me dis quand je me dis
que bien rangé ça ferait une belle photo
pour instagram
je me le dis mais je me dis sinon que
tout ce qui est double non mais attends
en plus je pense vraiment un truc je
n'arrive pas à l'exprimer mais en clair
le tonneau il est symétrique
donc tout ce qui est double doit se
répartir en haut ou en bas à gauche à
droite ce qui va être embêtant c'est ce
qui va être seul où je pense
je me permets de penser puisqu'il est
comme ça il faut déjà l'élargir ça de
toute manière ça s'est arrondi donc ça
ça va aller dans les côtés pensez pas
que ça irait aussi de moi alors je pense
que ça fait un truc un peu comme ça pour
beaucoup alors de ce côté là oui
peut-être plus pas du tout et c'est ça
que je voulais vous montrer qu' il faut
pas penser que ça y va quand ça ne va
pas ça ça doit faire ça donc ces deux
pièces là on sait que ça va
qu'est ce qu'on sait d'autre sur ce
casse tête on sait que loïc a passé à
peu près sept minutes 20 elle défère ça
veut dire qu'il ya un piège quelque part
ça par contre ça c'est une galère ça je
tais tu veux c'est pas ça mais en tout
cas ça fait toute la hauteur donc ça
doit se faire attendre à ce que ça fait
là merde c'est un tonneau car est un
tonneau qui est aussi haut que large pas
si c'est une caractéristique des
tonneaux est aussi haut que large
est ce que est ce que si je mets cela
est-ce qu'on récupérerai pas à peu près
le parce qu'on n'est pas sur un cercle
parfait
dites-moi la ligue le mans dans les
commentaires à ce que ça c'est un cercle
parfait est ce que ça se serait pas le
bon début et du coup je garde mon idée
de construire symétriquement les deux
axes de la symétrie
ça ne veut rien dire du tout attention
il ya des pièges dans ce que je peux
dire est ce que eux je peux pas les
bourgs et là dedans parce que en fait là
je sais pas si vous voyez bien sûr cette
caméra mais il ya un arrondi comme ça
qui dit arrondies et oui pas qu'on
fabien qui dit arrondi il regarde
regarde et constatez avec moi cet
arrondi n'est-il pas parfaitement un
briquet vraiment que je pensais à
embaucher des amis
sinon si ça dépasse pas tant que ça à
bella on est pas mal là franchement moi
je préfère un tonneau un peu plus aéré
un tonneau qui vit un tonneau qui
respire un tonneau qui a une sensation
de liberté un tonneau qui entonnent le
chant des partisans
entonne tonneau plutôt qu'attendre
enfermer ses coins de ne renfermer sein
de notre triste
ces tonneaux qui voient pas la lumière
de l'intérieur c'est un tonneau qui a le
coeur noir sombre ça faisant cette
taille là pour l'instant c'est simple je
sens que je me faire ken quand même un
moment mais ça on peut en mettre un au
dessus et en dessous comme ceux ci ce
qui nous reste sept petites fentes bon a
priori on a rien qui feinte la thalie de
hockey c'est là où ça commence a merdé
écoute moi je mets ça là je mets ça ici
[Musique]
ici
je mets ça s'est passé le pire c'est que
c'est pas si mal on dit je dis ça pour
faire le combler je mets ça par là comme
ça lui je le pose délicatement ici je
pense qu on est sur un tonneau bien
réussie pourrait faire un joli zoom
dessus un truc bien joli travaux sa mère
oui bon bah c'est bon on continue j'ai
compris qu'on peut que rigoler un peu
con côté casse tête je veux dire c'est
quand même l'activité la plus fun du
monde des esprits pourquoi je cite peu
d'amis non mais ça ça me semble être la
bonne base avec ça après la la tacc et à
presse ici apparemment par contre y en a
beaucoup
vous savez il est 6 heures du matin pour
moi aussi comment tourner vous voyez
peut-être cette vidéo les mercredis à 6h
à s'asseoir à 6 heures mais moi aussi je
les fais tôt le matin et un moment donné
on a on a le droit de craquer alors nous
pouvons manipuler cette zone comme un
petit ascenseur
parce que ce serait pas une solution
pour le défaire loïc accélération
décélère loïc décélère ouais voilà merci
parce qu'en fait là je te disais durant
l'accélérer que ça ça correspond pas mal
aux rainures
là aussi il ya une rainure et il ya un
arrondi et si je pense qu'il faut ce fut
vraiment il faut se fier en fait aux
pauvres aux lignes ça nous donne des
indices plus à l'arrondi du tonneau là
par contre j'ai une forme très étrange
ici mais peut-être qu'on pourrait
correspondre à sa part pékin
oui si ça marche j'ai pas dit de fierté
donc ça ça marcherait donc là en
symétrie il faudra être comme ça ouais
c'est pas si mal là franchement sans
déconner c'est bon il ne reste plus de
pièces dans ce casse tête
oh non non non au nom là là oh là là bon
lui c'est le petit frère de celui que
j'avais mis en bas comme ça donc là je
le mets hao comme ça et maintenant il
faut faire rentrer depuis il faut le
faire rentrer là mais ça fonctionne je
te jure que ça fonctionne parce qu'en
fait là vous voyez dans ce trou là on
voit que au bout il ya un petit bout de
bois
du coup vous avez pas vu mais là on voit
vraiment au bout qu'un tout petit bout
de bois
c'est ce petit bout de bois ici je pense
que je peux le crocheter comme ça
comment je fais en fait pour mettre ça
de temps quoi parce que si lui je le
mets là comme ça avec les rainures en
plus ça colle un adversaire
[Musique]
si je crois que c'est je pense que je
pense que c'est à la bonne taille
c'est à la bonne taille ok donc ça ça la
bonne taille en fait non par contre
c'est pour rentrer lui c'est pas ça non
ah c'est hyper frustrant parce qu'en
fait là c'est sûr c'est sur kiki qui se
montrent comme ça alors j'avais tout ce
dont je peux faire pour le si je mets
lui d'abord en prem's ça c'est bien et
qu'après attentif le jure j'ai une idée
je la vérité j'ai une idée je n'ai même
pas vu pas à mettre le il avait senti
arriver grâce à la petite musique que tu
mets au montage on dit il se passe
quelque chose
ceci est un casse tête de réseau lui
mais voilà tous nos catcheurs sacrées
option il est très cool ces tonneaux je
vous mets le lien comme d'habitude dans
la description si vous voulez l'acheter
alors j'ai écouté vos commentaires
j'essaie d'en prendre des qui coûte un
peu moins cher parce que lui je crois
qu'il est à 15 euros là sur le lièvre ou
mai mais des fois il y en a elles que
j'ai vraiment eu envie d'essayer qui
coûte plus cher c'est comme ça quoi
c'est aussi pour redresser des
casse-tête sur la chaîne lui je vous le
fais aussi gagner comme instagram suffit
d'aller sur cette photo que j'ai publié
sur taïwan et vous avez toutes les
indications parce qu'on sait pas un tout
accéléré pour voir en combien de temps
on peut le défaire et le refaire je mets
un chronomètre
[Musique]
crac une vingtaine cette vidéo ait pu
faire une minute 22 si je m'étais
entraîné avant qu'eux-mêmes et du coup
ça c'est pas faux c'est pas faux c'est
vraiment vrai du coup merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo vous pouvez lalique
et comme d'habitude c'est important
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner si vous
découvrez la chaîne que vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous avez déjà regardé de trois
vidéos bombe à vous piquer la ici vous
avez la vidéo sur le cul de chouettes
donc j'ai dit c'est pas faux je me la
vidéo sûr que tout est en ce moment le
cul tu souhaites c'est mortel
ici vous avez une vidéo qui devrait vous
intéresser parce que c'est l'algorithme
qui choisis pour vous lorsque vous avez
regardez juste avant de terminer j'ai
oublié de vous dire je vais être en
spectacle à la la la la la la il a et
puis vous avez qu à regarder cette carte
le dirait en descriptions à très bientôt
ciao